hey everyone welcome to et I'm Liana
Galera and I'm joined right now about
the one and only danielle Panabaker
right so good to see you so happy to be
here thank you so much for coming in of
course congratulations Danielle for
those of you who have been living
underneath the rock it is danielle
panabaker directorial debut in tonight's
episode of the flash I'm so excited for
you we're gonna be taking your fan
questions so start sending them in to me
and I'll pass them along to Danielle
but kicking things off when did you
first get that spark that you knew that
you wanted to step behind the camera I
think I've always been fascinated by you
know everything that goes into creating
a movie or an episode of television and
something I paid attention to for years
and then in season 3 of the flash I got
to watch Tom Cavanagh direct and he's
obviously a friend and it's sort of
turned into a mentor and watching him
direct on season 3 was really incredible
and I started asking questions and
saying is this something that I could do
so in season 4 he directed season 4
episode 4 I shadowed him yeah which was
really educational and informative and
at that point you know I started to feel
like I was ready to take it on and so I
understand that there are different
steps that you had to do in order to
kind of get prepared for that and Warner
Brothers really helped you out with that
what was that process like it was great
you know I was very lucky I was
incredibly supported Greg Berlanti asked
me probably in like January of last year
if I'd be interested in directing and I
said of course absolutely and the
support I got from Greg and Todd helping
our executive producer was really
incredible so last summer I did a
program through Warner Brothers and it's
their directing program and it was a
nine week program all summer and it just
they sort of walk you through step by
step everything that these two
incredible women it's taught by two
female directors amazing awesome
Bethenny Bruni and Mary Lou belly and
they're wonderful they were they could
be tough at times but there were great
teachers and you know between shadowing
and the program and then reading as much
as I could and asking advice from as
many people as I can I got to direct
this year I'm so excited for you Tom
obviously is such an incredible direct
Durand he's done so many episodes of the
flash so far what was the biggest piece
of advice that you were able to glean
from him he gave me a lot of advice it
was really more in watching him work
though he's very he's a very generous
director and he's a very collaborative
director you know sometimes directors
can come in and it's their vision and
it's their way or the highway
but with Tom you know he really works
with everyone to bring their best foot
forward and I tried to emulate that you
know as I was directing as well as
collaborating with everyone and trying
to see what their best ideas were and
it's always you know the best idea wins
it doesn't matter whose idea it is I
love the fact that we're seeing you step
behind the camera and that you're the
first female from the CW arrowverse to
do so this you know such a big deal I
didn't realize that until you send it at
comic-con last year like I was blown
away it's crazy I mean never that never
occurred to me while I was trying to
direct and you know doing everything I
could but I've actually been really
impressed by so since since the
announcement was made that I was
directing I've really been impressed by
the number of women who've reached out
to me and said I'm interested in
directing how did you do it and being
able to sort of pay it forward and
support them in that way that's amazing
it's been great it's like something I
wasn't expecting at all as you've gone
you you're typically in front of the
camera yes and you're stepping behind
the camera but you're also still in
front of the camera yes what was the
most challenging aspect that you learned
um you know every day presented a
different challenge it was funny I bet
my friend Beth Schwartz who's a
showrunner on arrow I was texting her at
one point just a little bit frustrated
with the way some things have gone and
she said you know TV directing is all
about you know being malleable and
working with whatever problem and
problem solving and you know again every
day was a new challenge my first day of
directing was the day where I had to
direct myself it was only one day in the
episode where I had to direct myself and
of course everybody said try and make
your first day easy well because of
scheduling we couldn't do that and so my
first day was not only directing for the
first time but also directing myself
which I didn't love like I really just
wanted to be a director I wanted to sit
and watch the monitors and make sure I
was getting the performances I needed
and the camera was getting what I needed
it to and and it was difficult not to
being able to watch that was Danielle
just add
gutter lines account she might have been
a little distracted but that's okay um
the coolest thing about me I was talking
about myself I was not talking about
Danny Nicolay oh I'm so talented I still
always forget that it's - Danielle's cuz
I call her Danny as well it was so funny
we were shooting something last week
that was grant to Jess's and to Danny's
and as we cared for the finale
yeah um tonight's episode is really
special though you got to direct
something that's totally different
you're directing Nora's origin episode
when when Todd told you that that was
gonna be your episode what was your
initial reaction I was really excited
you know I think Jessica's been
unbelievable on the show this year I
mean she's really done a lot of the
heavy lifting and she's had an
incredible storyline and I was excited
to get to collaborate and work with her
just to begin with and you know I also
really wanted to do well for her and
again she's in almost every scene of
this episode and she really shines so it
was great it was also you know we're
basically - it's basically Nora's pilot
without it being a pilot so it was a lot
it was ambitious there were a lot of
things that we had to accomplish in one
episode but it was great I loved it well
I got to see a sneak peek of tonight's
episode and I saw a rough cut and it had
a lot of things in it that you don't
typically get to see in the finalized
product and you see men on wires and
yeah actual stunts and it really makes
you realize oh my gosh they're actually
throwing these men around they're not
doing this in post was that challenging
for you as a director to orchestrate all
that I mean something like that is
really informative because you begin to
understand you know how many hundreds if
not thousands of people work on an
episode of television to make it come
together and look great and that was
honestly one of the most enjoyable
aspects of directing for me was
collaborating with all these different
departments in a very different way you
know going to our stunt coordinator John
Carlton saying all right here's my idea
and he would think about and can come
back with a way to make it even better
and so you know when you see a rough cut
you do see all the wires you see where
all the visual effects are going in
later and you begin to understand like
how much the actors are sort of acting
to nothing and just using their
imagination you know for us
gorilla grodd is
a tennis ball on the end of the stick so
and then when you see him afterwards
yeah oh my god they did a great job
absolutely his fall oh I still loved
that episode I showed that I thought it
was really great I did too king shark
and gorilla grodd I mean yeah so
ambitious but I mean shout out to Arman
and his special effects team like they
did an incredible job yeah
we're starting getting so many amazing
fan questions and right now
yeah hey says did you choose the episode
that you got to direct because it was
gonna be this big episode or did you not
want to know what it was beforehand no I
mean so when they assign directors they
they have a schedule and they are sort
of fitting directors into this schedule
and there's almost no way of knowing
what episodes are gonna direct like you
know obviously the premiere is a big
episode and the crossover is a big
episode and the finale is a big episode
but you never know where in there you're
gonna fall sometimes you'll get a
smaller episode sometimes you get a
bigger one so when they assign me
episode 18 I had no idea where it was
gonna fall in the spectrum and then in
here it is yes and essentially you know
I got an origin story which to me is
really important yeah
Jared van der Poel Oh Jared van der Poel
sorry Jared wants to know what was your
favorite part of directing episode 18 I
think like I said before getting to
collaborate with all the different
departments a new unique way you know
everybody obviously the actors are
incredibly talented on flash and you see
that every week but there's so many
people behind the scenes that do great
work and getting to you know work with
them and and collaborate and come up
with cool ideas was great I'm switching
over into some killer Frost's questions
fandom guy wants to know Panabaker do
you like playing killer frost evil or
the killer frost on team flash and what
do you think is more in store for
Kaitlyn in the love department in terms
of killer frost actually have really
loved her storyline this year I feel
like they did a great job sort of
developing the relationship between
Kaitlyn and killer frost these two
people these two very distinct very
different people who also happen to
occupy the same body and I feel like it
was really cool to see their
relationship evolve as they were leaving
notes for each other you know and there
was some tension when killer frost was
destroying Kaitlyn's work so it was cool
it was great I loved seeing that and
I'm interested in sort of where she is
now and that she sort of she he's a
member of team flash but sometimes she's
a little disgruntled about it sometimes
she's not so thrilled about it I love
when there's like the random telepathic
moments where she's like here we go
nope she's out yeah tap it out for this
one not interested so I think it's cool
it's been it's been really fun yeah um
as for Caitlin's love life I don't know
I don't know that that I feel like the
relationship she's been focused on this
years her relationship with killer frogs
so sort of her a relationship with
herself so I don't know if there's
romance for her this season but maybe
next year mm-hmm
how have you been feeling about killer
frost look this year because she's a
little different well it's different you
know
I want a new suit I want a new suit that
was my next question but you know the
season four suit was a different you
know was different than the season three
suit and I want a new suit absolutely um
so it's you know killer frost is a
little bit like vibe in that she and
like most of the superheroes that she
has to go somewhere and put her suit on
like flash has to put his suit on so I'm
excited to see what her suit looks like
whenever she gets it
have you been brainstorming yes
absolutely
I like and and hopefully this is a
little bit evident in the episode of
directed as well you know I got the
villain of Godspeed and that first thing
I did was go to the comic book so it's
the same thing with the killer frost
suit like we have such a wealth of
source material they're like why not
start there for some inspiration yeah I
love it and God speed it looks so cool
he looks fantastic a turistic but also
very menacing
yeah a keen yes very clear that was a
white suit yeah
we're getting so much love for you right
now tahoe says go Danielle with like so
many little green hearts
I'm fighter Colin says she deserves all
of this three heart eye emojis and one
crying emoji I do have to say like the
support I have felt over the last six
months two years I've been on this
journey has been incredible both from
friends and family and the fans like I
am so very grateful so thanks guys we
have another question from ration mine's
78 would you direct a movie since you
tried your hand on directing an episode
of the flash I would love to I feel like
you know I'm still
learning I feel like I learned a lot
over my first experience directing you
know it's a rarity to be able to step on
the camera in that position like you are
so lucky to be given this opportunity
and that was not lost on me so I want to
keep directing I want to keep directing
flash I'd love to maybe go to some of
the other CW shows Warner Brothers shows
and yes I went out right now let's make
this happen I would totally love to
direct Riverdale it's cool like it's got
a really specific vibe I love ya so
something like that
I mean yeah I'd love that it would be
great yeah I would love it I think it
would be fine I'm like you know it's all
sort of in that Berlin T universe so
hopefully they let me come play I think
you would also be amazing a Supergirl oh
thank you I would love to direct
Supergirl as well I feel like that show
in terms of like our sort of arrowverse
world is most similar to flash arrow can
be a little bit more action heavy and
Legends is a bit more you know they're
fun they're a little more wacky for sure
yeah but I think Supergirl would fit
really naturally mhm let's talk a little
bit about tonight's episode okay when we
last left off it was a big bombshell
that Nora has been chatting with Mr Bond
and / great we've known it as the
audience for quite some time but this is
a really big shock to Barry and iris and
now they're trying to process this news
where do we go from here
I mean it is it is a big deal and I
think it's sort of nice that we give
these parents and this couple some time
to process that you know we open the
episode with it almost being a fight
between Barry and iris because they
don't see it the same way like Barry
experienced watching this man eobard
thawne kill his mother right in front of
him when he was a child and you know I
don't know that he's even gotten over
that yet and then to find out that his
daughter is now working with this man
yeah it's such a dagger to him so it's
gonna be a bit of a challenge for them
to work through as a couple and as
parents what can you tease you guys are
all wrapped on season 5 fairly by the
skin of our teeth how was it how are you
feeling about this finale what can you
tease for the fans the finale is gonna
be epic
I am always blown away it feels like
year after year they try and find a way
to top themselves a lot of night shoots
last week to get everything we need
but I think it's gonna be I think it's
gonna be great
yeah well it's crazy that arrow is
ending next year yes this has been the
mothership this is what launched the CW
verse and then flash came along shortly
after they'd been a model for flash and
well you know the way they do you know
the big the first nine episodes are
really big and like a lot of you know I
was able to look to a lot of the people
on arrow and see how they were handling
things well and we first met Caitlin on
arrow yes
so it's yeah it still doesn't quite feel
real because it's like okay we'll go
back in the summer and we'll keep going
and we'll keep filming they'll still be
there but I'm sure it will hit me at
some point yeah be pretty sad have they
told you anything about what you can
expect from the crossover next year who
I mean as the fans are already asking
about it mark made an announcement I
think it wasn't tcas or something
earlier this year that they were gonna
be bigger than ever ever and I was like
oh no we're exhausting they are
exhausting they're challenged but guys
we do it for you we do it for the fans
for sure they I think honestly I'm not
sure how much they've broken those
stories yet the writers room I think
just opened for season six like maybe
yesterday so they're barely getting
started so I truly don't know much but
you just answered Jessie's questions she
said I love you so much Danielle and I
love your show but is this the last
season of the flash no this is not the
last season of the flash where you're
very lucky we'll be starting season six
and a couple months and not very long so
we'll definitely be around for at least
one more year you get to relax on your
hiatus yes yes I'm happy to be home I
just got home last night yeah very happy
well I really appreciate you coming in
thank you so much we're always hanging
you so much to the fans
be sure to check in tonight to the flash
to see Danielle's directorial debut it
airs Tuesdays at 8 p.m. on the CW we'll
see you next time thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]